i had someone within the you know
gymnastics community
tell me the day of my olympic
competition the day of all around
a phenomenal routine you're overweight
the judges aren't going to like it
you're not going to win because of it
and you should have worked harder and i
remember again
as 16 year old kid it was just like this
scarring moment for me
but i'm really proud now being
28 looking back it shook me for a second
but then i was like you know what i'm
i'm really good at what i do
and i've been winning these competitions
and i
like i'm here for a reason i was just
it kind of shaped who i am today because
someone tried telling me very early on
that because of
who i was what i looked like how i acted
i wasn't going to become
something and it's been like my mission
in life to prove people wrong now which
i love
i'm shawn johnson east and today i'm
unfiltered from my home
my makeup routine now that i'm a mom
takes me
maybe five maybe 10 minutes
and doing makeup during quarantine is uh
very rare
i hardly shower let alone get out of
sweats
[Music]
especially chasing an almost
one-year-old around i would say the
first time i recognized beauty i think
it has to be at the olympics
it was all about seeing different
athletes and their passions
and their talent on the world's biggest
stage and i thought that was true beauty
seeing how
everyone looked so so different but yet
was just so incredible and i think it
was a good
first lesson for me to learn my first
makeup
step is i already put moisturizer on so
primer
[Music]
life in des moines iowa was
pretty much anything and everything you
would expect from like a midwest
small town movie we spent every day
outside sitting in lawn chairs in our
driveway
i played capture the flag every friday
with every kid
and it was amazing
but do i remember life without
gymnastics
um not really it's just
it was always my passion as a kid and so
i just spent every waking second even
like at home
thinking about it and playing and i
would use like my neighbor's fence as a
beam it was
my favorite thing in the whole world
[Music]
i was really really lucky in gymnastics
i had like
a different schedule and i only did 20
hours versus like the normal 40.
but i was really lucky to have a coach
that celebrated me having
an identity outside of gymnastics
gymnastics wasn't this like olympic
sport for me it was just
a hobby that my coach you know
talked about as like an after-school
activity
i'm not a makeup guru so if i do all
this wrong to all the makeup artists out
there
sorry i just i put it under my eyes
and my nose
a little bit here maybe that's a lot i
don't know
i am baking now
beautiful so i'm going to be taking a
look back
at some of my most iconic gymnastics
moments
i think the moment i was most like proud
of was my olympic all-around
as soon as i came in second and i came
in second to my teammate and best friend
just being on the podium and still
seeing the united states flag
it was everything that i dreamt of and i
just i felt so proud and
on top of that i competed at the
olympics back in my coach's hometown and
he had never been back to china
since he left until that like the
olympics and so it was just like it was
this really special kind of family
all-encompassing moment for me i'd say
at least
happy to share was probably just my
retirement
in 2012 i'm trying to come back and make
the 2012 olympic team
oh no i was going through just a lot
emotionally and as a 19 year old kid
i was in like a bad relationship i
didn't really want to be back in the
sport i was going through an eating
disorder i felt
like depressed it's a hard moment for me
but it was one of the most
pivotal and life lesson learning moments
of my
my career a phenomenal routine
i had someone within the you know
gymnastics community
tell me the day of my olympic
competition the day of all around
you're overweight the judges aren't
going to like it
you're not going to win because of it
and you should have worked harder
and i remember again as a 16 year old
kid it was just like
this scarring moment for me but
i'm really proud now being 28
looking back it shook me for a second
but then i was like you know what i'm
i'm really good at what i do
and i've been winning these competitions
and i
like i'm here for a reason i was just
it kind of shaped who i am today because
someone tried telling me very early on
that because of
who i was what i looked like how i acted
i wasn't going to become something
and it's been like my mission in life to
prove people wrong now which i
i have love
every life lesson that i like have
ingrained in my soul
comes from gymnastics i think that's one
of the most beautiful things about the
sport
and one of my favorite things about the
sport and it's something my coach taught
me on like
day one of my classes with him is you
will never
succeed at anything until you fail at it
miserably
big skill i think that's one of the most
beautiful things about gymnastics is
you literally have to split a beam or
fall on your face or fall
a thousand times before you ever learn a
new skill
you should fail you should fall you
should make mistakes and learn from them
and if you keep working on it you will
succeed i think just a lot of people
forget that
please welcome back america's newest
sweetheart shawn johnson
becoming quote unquote like instantly
famous right for the olympics
was probably the hardest part of the
olympics for me
i was going to compete finish out my
high school kind of like stint
go to college and just live this normal
life and
when things kind of took off right after
the olympics years just started going by
and i was like wait
my plan is no longer my plan and people
started having opinions over my plan
and people started trying to control my
life and
control what i looked like and what i
said and how i acted
it's a lot of pressure because i i
wasn't allowed to make a mistake
and what 16 year old doesn't make a
million mistakes in their life
these are taking forever
unexpected curveballs of life um
after like my husband eyes miscarriage
and
i don't know just the ups and downs of
life it's not easy
and it's emotional and you ball your
eyes out
and you lean on your community and your
family and your loved ones to kind of
heal through it
i'd say the biggest thing i learned
through the miscarriage is that
um i'm human and i can't control
everything
i felt like the hardest thing for my
husband and i to go through at that
time was
there's this weird feeling and
understanding of life as an athlete
it's like okay this happened i made this
mistake
i broke this bone whatever and there's a
prescription for it
it's like okay rehab this much
train this much extra and there's always
a solution
and with the miscarriage there wasn't a
solution
which i was not used to and
just learning very early that parenthood
means letting go of control
um was a very early lesson for us but
i think i just learned that you know
i'm human
[Music]
the organization that i have trusted my
entire life has failed
miserably i love these girls so much
usa gymnastics has gone through a lot
the gymnasts
have gone through a lot and they've gone
through a lot of things that they
never should have been subjected to
you can go through as much therapy and
healing
and money and lawsuits but nothing
nothing can take that back for the
athletes and
they can't they will forever be stripped
of that um
so in moving forward um
i think usa gymnastics is making
progress
but to have that
trust stripped from gymnasts and from an
organization
takes a long time to heal yes
i would put my daughter in gymnastics if
that's what she wants to do
but i don't think anybody that was a
part of that organization
during that time would put their
daughter in
and not be nervous growing up in the
the world of usa gymnastics i think
there were so many things
as an athlete that i knew was wrong i
knew people
were bad but at such an elite level
you have this you basically turn a blind
eye because
there's so many sacrifices made at such
an extreme level
and again mix into it being a child
you don't know what's too extreme
[Music]
you take people you know acting mean to
you
and saying hurtful things and abusing
power and system as like oh maybe that's
just what it's like at the elite level
and i think i turned a blind eye but
i was a kid and then now i'm like no
absolutely
i came out probably three years after
the olympics
and admitting that i had i had struggled
with eating disorders
uh depression anxiety i've been very
open about like eating disorders and
just everything that i went through but
i think it it plays a lot into like
identity um
transitioning from a sport that pushes
perfectionism
i didn't know how to set that aside when
my sport was done
so i restricted my calories and i
learned all these bad habits
because i thought that would achieve
perfection within my sport
outside of it there's so many pressures
that the world puts on you and as a kid
after gymnastics i was used to a coach
saying do this do that do this and you
achieve perfection
so when i didn't have my coach anymore i
took the world's advice and i was like
okay i need to do what vogue magazine
says i need to do what
instagram is telling me and i think if i
could go back and tell that girl i'd be
like well
everything you're doing is wrong because
the only way you can be successful
and be happy is by being yourself
and i didn't learn that for a while
it takes a long time to come out of all
of that stuff
to come out of eating disorders and body
dysmorphia and
to finally be comfortable with who you
are and
the skin you're in my husband was
another one
he was someone who truly loved me for me
and not what i had done
and he gave me a lot of confidence to
heal
what are you doing
you serious and then my biggest fear was
getting pregnant
because i thought with a changing body i
would
regress and go back into feeling
insecure
and i was just so shocked to find that
i had never been more confident in my
life
and i had a purpose and ever since
having my daughter
it's just a freedom that i've truly
never had that's for the first time in
my life i don't care about
myself i'm just like
i don't know my life and my body is for
my child
so yeah
mascara i have like
tiny eyelashes and i found that this
kind of helps me but
who knows might just be like a placebo
lips will take me two seconds
so this is what i uh do on like a daily
basis
not in quarantine so easy simple
nothing crazy
yes fresh face my perception of beauty
has evolved over the years
i think i've kind of come full circle to
where i started
i think something that i i loved
appreciating in beauty as a kid
was people's differences i think that's
the most beautiful thing about the
olympics in olympic sports is i would
walk around the olympic village and see
people of
every shape size and color and
every single one of them was an olympic
athlete
and that is like insanely beautiful
and i think i i fell into society's
definition of beauty for many years of
like
if you have to look like a model to be
beautiful
and i think i've come full circle after
having our daughter
and just knowing that beauty is truly
like an internal thing
it's your character and your confidence
and your passions and your beliefs and
beauty is just beauty is not makeup
i feel most beautiful with my husband
and my daughter
you know cameras off lights off just
being us to know that
i am his wife and a mother and
makes me feel beautiful because it's my
passion and it's what i love
and it puts me back at like the olympics
i just feel like i'm doing what i'm
supposed to be doing